all right let's go run in the dark what
do you say roll dog where we gone I'm
going to go up the Queen k where the
shoulders are wide we're less likely to
get hit by a car is the best bet
Safety's first
we he drive I'll have run along there
but the shoulders really narrow and a
car so unequal best off just
hitting the Queen Kari
sorry it's so dark guys but the Sun fell
down pretty quick it's only five-thirty
right now and it's Lena's rain already
hard this is roll dogs second run he did
it to our run early this early this
morning and now we're going out for
another two hour run so we're gonna go
hit the go hit the Queen k where it's
nice and safe and there's lights and see
how the legs feel how you feel buddy
feeling good I just wanted to give a
shout out to everybody out there is
watching the videos we've been getting
so many emails like cool emails from
people all over the place and just a
great response so you know we just were
just out here having a good time I
wanted you to share you know with you a
little bit of the day in the life as we
get ready for Ultraman and we had no
expectations and anybody was gonna care
but the fact that we actually have a
little bit of an audience is really cool
matter do you think about that I think
it's awesome you know it's just a lot of
people don't really know what goes on
behind the scenes
you know for iron man and Ultraman
traffic's but we're so blessed to be out
here in kailua-kona and we're having
unusual weather today we've never never
had the experience of rain we get it a
couple times a year this is the dry side
of the Big Island the other side is
known for quite wedding rings a long run
you love it doesn't ring that often on
this side where the lava fields arts
that's where all the resorts son of your
lenders nutter so it's a little unusual
but actually it's kind of refreshing hey
our avocados papayas and mangoes have to
get water from somewhere
so yeah I feel like we're like in like
LA it's kind of like Elliot Oh warmer
here yeah it's still really humid and
I'm still acclimating
you would never know that role dog was
in Hawaii right now because he decided
to wear his Parker parka yeah you gotta
keep warm we're gonna go skiing after
this and run and we're not joking
actually you can go up on top of Mauna
Kea and there's these on year-round or
there's always snow up there but you
know it's wintertime right now so this
rain will help put some powder up there
and there's snowboarders I'd like to go
up there so I don't know anywhere else
you could be snowboarding in an hour
later you can be surfing in the ocean
could you really well I guess that you
could go into your mouth walgreens
in an hour to get a surf film look at
average is that unusual
we replace novelty this is really behind
the same this is really what it takes
would be really easy to this bag is from
I'm tired
I really don't feel like going friday
I gotta get done it's stressing me out
I'm trying to balance the demands of the
training against
and think about what I do is I can
pretty much do it wherever I am most of
its on the phone and email so i have a
luxury of being able to still work when
I'm out of town with the time difference
in and the long training sessions that
we definitely put crimp on its stuff
it's tough to balance at all and get it
all done so it would have been easy to
just say I got too much work to do
entire star it's raining you know
we're so close to the race
I try to never miss a workout
that over two weeks out so it's time to
just suck it up
I have so much respect for all you out
there who have kids and you know not
only a full-time job but sometimes it's
50 to 60 hours a week and it's just you
guys are really the Ultraman absolutely
amazing you know most of you know what
role dog does he has a big beautiful
family on top of top of a big career and
he's out here battling but I think if
I'm wearing this hat too much i'm ready
to start losing some clients I think we
I think we can definitely take like that
so we're checking in with you queen kay
kailua-kona Thursday in the rain we're
gonna go pound the pavement for two
hours we're going to check back in with
you afterwards and let you know how
everything went but it's a right we say
roll roll dog out dogging jaedong so
Valley J dog out on the dog TV piece so
Jason Jason was blazing out there yeah
this beautiful man it was like the whole
time I thought you were right on my
heels and for like five miles i was
talking to you the same let's go let's
pick it up let's pick it up and it was
just beautiful but probably one of the
most beautiful experiences I ever had is
awesome run we went out we went out
seven turn around seven and i think i
got in right around 150 who won 52 but
dude you freakin hammered it today rule
dog put in almost 30 miles today man so
his legs he went when we went out his
legs were just freaking spent but uh I
think that's our freakin last big Rhine
you got a couple a couple long ones
coming up but um no for our I think the
nice i should check the schedule but i
think the next long run is a run/walk
going like like six miles six miles run
one mile walk five mile run one mile
walk four mile run
mile walk so i'll break this early yeah
focus on and that is to is on the speed
and hydration when you want so it will
it'll be a long time out running but
it'll be a different kind of run so yet
29 miles today there's a big day and we
got going on tomorrow tomorrow got a
hour and a half ocean swim i'm going to
try out my new wetsuit of its home in a
wet suit yet in the ocean so i'm going
to give out a spin so we'll check in
with you at the beach well dogs cheeks
are looking a little gone on guys it's
been I gotta get some nutrition yeah
we're going to go pound some carbs right
now long day good day now I get to go
home and be a lawyer what time are we
outdoors it's all eight o'clock feels
like midnight though yeah doesn't it so
there you go guys eight o'clock Ultraman
training kona hawaii 2009 ultraman
championships bringing it to you two
weeks out today i think right exactly
live and collect just told you we're
gonna bring you inside our world out
here so we're going to chalk this one up
and what do you say roll thai food jamba
juice what do you want that sounds good
16 at all it's more first talk to you
later guys peace love happiness Aloha